that pause heard loud and clear across
the valley today as well 8 news now
reporter Ryan Matthey takes us to one of
Las Vegas's longest running Memorial Day
Services right near downtown Las Vegas
there are 1600 Flags here at Woodland
Cemetery representing over 1600 veterans
laid to rest right here and amidst
barbecues and an extra day off work for
some veterans here saying these flags
representing what this day means to so
many
Lynn Schweitzer for one finds himself
here each year I had two uncles in the
Army who passed away I had a sister in
the Navy who passed away
day of Remembrance in questioning how he
made it out of the Air Force while so
many others did not been gone quite a
while but it's still you know it still
hits me right here there is an empty
seat at the table today this Memorial
Day service has been ongoing for 23
years a 40 acre Cemetery the oldest in
the city of Las Vegas listed on the
national register of historic places are
we really living the life to prove it
was worth it they paid for the ultimate
sacrifice for us Larry Davis with
Bunker's funeral homes and cemeteries
organizes it each year from the flags in
the ground
to the chorus singing over them we have
to keep the memory alive of these men
and women who lost their lives to keep
us free an annual tradition with
veterans like Schweitzer reminiscing
over those who were and what they left
behind makes me very happy makes me real
proud to be among the servicemen